hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend we have very special episode
today big massive star I'd say maybe one
of the biggest one of the most iconic
faces of the last uh easily 50 years of
film Harrison Ford uh and he was on the
podcast and there was some concern
because everyone's a Harrison Ford fan
everybody but
Gorly takes it to this other level
um I think the words creepy no come to
mind you idolize the man and I was
worried that you wouldn't behave
yourself Matt or you might soil yourself
or embarrass yourself in some way and I
want to applaud you because I thought
you handled yourself with a plum in this
yeah we talked about this on an earlier
episode and I think everything went
really well so much so that I think it's
safe to say that he and I are friends
well I'd like to see you try and cash
that and check it would be fun to watch
you escorted off the Ford estate by nine
by nine robotics
security cards Stormtroopers yeah
exactly I would I would pay anything to
see you tossed out of his house like uh
like a drunk in an old movie he gets
tossed out of a bar and they just grab
you by the pants and throw you out I
don't know why we can't just leave it as
fact that we don't need to test it it
just is you know guys change exchange
numbers no but we didn't need to because
we I think we were beyond that how are
you no no no no no yeah you're not part
of friendship yeah you're not Beyond it
um you don't need to call someone when
you're always hanging out you know what
I mean oh I see you don't need his
number because you'll always be right
next to each other yeah yeah yeah that
hasn't started yet but I'm assuming it's
any day now any day now there's gonna be
a knock at your door and uh you're going
to open it and he's going to be there as
Indiana Jones and he will have landed
he's going to whip you to death
I'll take it I'll take it you'd be happy
to go out that way wouldn't you yeah no
I thought you did a I thought you were
very good you were very professional you
are I give you a hard time but you are
uh at your core a pro and I thought you
were you are you're a professional uh
you handle yourself well uh Sona you are
not a professional
um
take on me but okay I should have just
guessed well would you say you're would
you say you're a lot of things a lot of
great things would you say you're a
professional uh if
I mean
it came in excuse you he came in and I
was very very professional a lot of
times when you're around serious people
I am a very professional person so yeah
I do think that I was being professional
and I think that I it's not like I'm
walking in like you know puffing on a
joint and eating Cheetos and being like
yo Harry what's up I didn't do that wow
you would have appreciated that yeah
first of all I think he would have been
fine with that especially if you would
you didn't Bogart That Joint uh but I
think that uh yeah you set a pretty low
bar for yourself you said as long as I
don't walk in eating Cheetos and uh
smoking a massive blunt then I'm a
professional so I will say I think that
day you did actually come in from the
kitchen with a snack bag of something
like little Cheetos or something yeah
you did that's what I do every day when
we record so that's not dip but I think
that I was being a professional I think
everybody was on their best behavior we
just wanted Harrison Ford to think we
were cool can I say I was not on my best
behavior I I I was not well behaved I
said I said I wasn't even sure he was in
the Star Wars films because he doesn't
know that's right you'll hear that you
know you don't really pop in those
movies
I'm surprised he didn't come across the
table you're the problem
you know what's so funny I came in as I
do often hot I come in
and you know trying to give you guys a
hard time and while I was talking to you
realized I am the one who's
unprofessional I am the problem yes and
and I'm saying this like it's a therapy
session and I just realized that for the
first time but no I that's a
breakthrough for me I am you're also
saying it like we haven't realized that
from day one I don't care what you guys
realize I'm having my own breakthrough
this is about me I'm the patient but
I've said this many times that the fish
rots from the head and you're the head
of this fish so I'm a rotting fish head
you what's the fit what's the head rots
the rest of the thing rots and you no no
we all know we know how it works you
don't need to break this down explain it
I'm sorry yeah I'm still not clear I
don't know if you could really so the
fish rots from the head that means that
means Conan is the head of fish what
kind of fish what is it is it a
freshwater fish or is it a saltwater
fish
I think it's a it's a saltwater fish
okay why does that make a difference
I've learned a lot about fishing sure
well you know me I'm a guy that likes to
get out on the sea I like that air in my
face
um I come from a long line of fishermen
and uh I yes microbiologist okay my
father Yes my father's a microbiologist
but before that he was uh a Groton
fisherman he wore a big yellow Groton
Fisherman's outfit
and uh then he was so bad at it they
said I think you need to go get a
microscope
[Laughter]
he's the only fish you're catching are
so tiny we can't even see them so that's
how we did it all right well we should
get let's just say I admit I'm the uh I
am the weak Link in this chain today but
man we had a really good time